Medical experts and the government warn
that if the coronavirus continues to spread,
the virus could become an
even more dangerous variant than the current
delta variant.
to the
white house says americans
can prevent coronavirus from
becoming even more dangerous with vaccines
the virus changes and gets stronger
when people infect each other
but vaccines can stop the
virus that's why doctors  and the
government encourage all eligible people
to get vaccinated
fauci also explained that these vaccines
are safe and that they were developed
so quickly in part because this
class of vaccines has been in
use for decades
jeffries sainz the director of
the coronavirus response team at the
White House said on Thursday that in the previous
24 hours, 860,000 vacuums were administered
nas nationwide and
that means efforts to educate
more people are working
hobbit 19 vaccines were
licensed for emergency use
but the food and
drug administration says facer's vaccine
could receive full clearance in
the next few  weeks reporting in
washington
alexandra limón